all right let's get into audience
questions for the week sort of the last
time the last time that it's for the
Friday show we will take more audience
questions but next week we've got a
weird schedule because of the holiday
anyway who cares this is one of the last
times will be taking audience questions
for the year and the first question is
hey David why can't Barron Trump ever be
mentioned publicly according to
Republicans but it's fine for Trump to a
tacit Greta toon burg Greta toon burg of
course TIME's Person of the Year the
European climate activists 16 or 17 year
old climate activists so I agree with
you it makes no sense that merely
mentioning Barron is off limits but the
president himself is going after this
young girl who is a climate activists
now when I tweeted about this I got a
bunch of tweets from right-wingers
saying David don't you understand the
difference Greta Thun Berg is a public
figure by choice she is an activist she
is doing something and opening herself
up to criticism Barron is just the
president's son he has not done anything
publicly he is not trying to be in the
public eye that's why it's unfair to
mention Baron but Greta soon Berg is a
willing public figure and therefore she
can be attacked listen what was
mentioned about Barron Trump was
literally a word pun it wasn't about
Barron Trump a professor law professor
Carlin who testified in the House
impeachment hearings a couple of weeks
ago in talking about how the president
Donald Trump has a desire for unchecked
power similar to that of a monarch she
said Barron Trump can't also be a baron
right so like be aro n the low level
figure of a monarchy it's some kind of
royal position right a bear be aro and
lowercase not a proper noun it's just a
word pun okay and Republicans went crazy
like Baron Trump as an individual was
being attacked in some way it's just a
language convenience that's all it is
there was no actual criticism of Barron
the criticism is of Donald Trump
who has children the adult ones who have
just been installed in positions of
notoriety privilege and power without
being elected without being confirmed by
the Senate and that is the problem when
Trump goes after Greta toon burg as an
individual seems to sort of ridicule err
even for the idiosyncrasies that are
part of her being mildly autistic when
people go against her attack her motives
or her demeanor her physical appearance
all this stuff you're really saying that
that's the same as a word pun that had
nothing to do whatsoever with Baron
Trump as a person you got to give me a
break and then even more pathetic by the
way is that Trump's wife the first lady
Melania Trump has very publicly said her
cause is bullying she doesn't want
bullying she doesn't want cyber bullying
she doesn't want school bullying or any
kind of bullying and then when the
opportunity presents itself where her
husband is bullying
Greta Thun Berg she initially says
nothing and then I believe I'm going
from memory here actually said that
Greta sort of brought it on herself in
some way I don't actually it was over
the weekend and I was so sickened by the
mere concept of it I didn't research it
but said something along the lines of
well she did something to deserve the
criticism these people don't get they
the right claims to be all about
principles and then when they actually
get an opportunity to live their
principles it turns out that turns out
that the principles don't even matter
remotely it's absolutely stunning and
disgusting there is no comparison
between a attacking Greta Thun Berg the
way Republicans have attacked her they
are so triggered by her verses a
language pun related to Baron Trump and
a baron of royalty I don't even take the
the criticism seriously and the the only
defense I've seen is willing versus
unwilling public figure very easily
debunk Obol